[Applause]
Hollywood royalty
[Applause]
a shocking double elimination on the
masked singer there's a monster there is
a bead this is so crazy
I wanted everyone to know that I can
sing to Rumer Willis the lion and Joey
Fatone the rabbit for the latest singing
celebrities in disguise to get the boot
before their reveal the pair slayed the
competition week after week with their
incredible performances and gave the
audience some major clues
I'm just the lion who wants to be heard
not the child of my parents not the
Empire I was born into throughout the
competition I've been singing as many
different genres as possible to throw
the paddle off myself and to prove that
I'm a versatile performer in my own life
although we'll have to keep watching to
find out who the rest of the secret
singing stars are the masked singer
confirmed that they're coming back for
season two et recently spoke with the
panelists about the exciting news it is
a gift that keeps on giving it is like
it it's so much fun to be on that show
so chuffed and over the moon that the
show is so well received because we
never expected this
this success we always hoped it would be
but it exceeded our expectations
obviously I really had intuition of this
working but when I try to explain it to
people before it aired they looked at me
like I was nuts and now that it's aired
everyone you know you love the mass
singer how many of your [ __ ] friends are
now texting you being like um I'd love
to be a part of the show that's a good
question have you here to share any
names
they're your friends you're like you're
like nothing not it not good enough
we're just riding the wave right now
it's all--it's Point Break time
[Music]